ha sido una semana muy difícil para que
no sea esta localidad del estado de
wisconsin que ha visto como la visita de
don al tram aprovecha para generar más
polémica hemos tenido tensión en las
calles constante y la visita de don al
tram ha sido para apuntar y señalar
aquellos que causan disturbios como ante
americanos y anti policía y precisamente
sus acciones son muy claras y serán las
de donar un millón de dólares de fondos
federales para la policía local de que
no sea cuatro millones de dólares para
los comercios afectados por las
destrozos como por ejemplo este
concesionario de coches completamente
calcinado momentos después de que se
hicieran virales las imágenes de los
disparos al afroamericano james o break
precisamente sus familiares hoy se han
reunido para atacar al presidente donald
trump mostrar apoyo público al demócrata
joe biden y ambos candidatos en la
contienda de noviembre están intentando
sacarle rédito político a una situación
que en el caso de donald trump estaba
realmente complicada con la situación
económica y con la gestión del
coronavirus y en cambio ahora está
agarrándose a la ley y al orden como
baza política para su posible reelección